Donald sterling we now all know what
happened
so it's just passport and go to what
happened yesterday
which was Adam Silver the new NBA
commissioner laying down the hammer
let's go to the videotape effective
immediately in
I am painting mister sterling
for life from any association
with the Clippers organization or the
NBA
in mister sterling may not attend
any NBA games or practices when
he may not be present any Clippers
facility
and and he may not participate in any
business
or player personnel decisions involving
the team in he will also be barred from
attending
NBA Board of Governors meetings or
participating
any other League activity in
I'm also finding mister sterling 2.5
million dollars
the maximum amount allowed under
the NBA constitutional okay so if you
were hiding under a rock
ten-second recap Donald sterling order
the Clippers
nine minute audiotape incredibly racist
while talking to his black and Mexican
girlfriend will get a nap are
me just a second I mean there's so many
layers that this I am
let's just start with just broad racism
its it hasn't gone anywhere has it I no
I I thought Obama got elected I think
it's pretty much cut the clothes that
said if we had a little dip
when Obama came in with their little dip
in a feeling like maybe we're getting
past this and we're pose racial
and now it's starting to rear its ugly
head again do you think that's gonna be
no yeah I think we'll Fort 10 seconds
when Obama got what Obama got elected
that's pretty it was amazing that mean
the fact that the guy was black
and had this weird name I thought
there's no way america's going for this
and they did it was great
but yeah it that it just pushed all the
buttons and all love the fear
the white males who are losing the
battle sorry guys
have banned the rabbit run red yeah
good run this and I yeah it's
it's now it's now seeping out every
corner have our culture
so his weird name are you saying that's
why they always say Barack Hussein the
Obama theorizes that area that they do
that Rick racism did I thought we were
past it but I guess there
I'll show you how smart are racist is to
hey
I'm a charger I head I'm done I'm a
charger all day im
I come on down to I
Mr Ford dealership but less Eurasian
pull my head up there
that okay come on down to the bath house
unless you're gay
well but yeah this guy okay at the
he's not a very bright guy he wasn't
destined to be anything but briefly
lucky
yeah I will you guys feel slightly
different if he didn't have this crazy
history of racism you know Elgin Baylor
the former GM but the Clippers
had gotten into him I got into some
stuff with him there's been a
this slum lord issue that he didn't want
black and Hispanic people reading his
apartment
if this had been somebody that had a
perfectly clean record as far as we know
would you feel different about a private
phone
absolutely and there is an issue around
the privacy that phone call and cream
abdul-jabbar
wrote a great little piece ending for
time magazine online
and he talked about that part a bit that
he'd didn't like that part of it
but yeah it might be like a michael
richards moment or something results
earlier in your nose but
the point that Kareem abdul-jabbar made
in these other people is that this guy's
been doing this for years and years
he's known his reputation in the city
for being like this
and no one made a fuss about it then so
but it takes something like this you
know a TMZ moment in our culture
to actually pushed to push him over the
edge this new media we have
that you know they're discounting is all
that's just the alternate media or
that's just citizen journalism
has having gargantuan sledgehammer
impact on circumstances there was the
kid
who had alzheimer's in schools being
bullied so you're
Aspergers yeah as burgers and install
any records the
the bullies and they sue him and so the
a the mass media took over
and they drop the suit may ran and hid
yeah
and there's some other circumstances
like that Archer yes powerful but it is
also
there's an issue i mean you know this
was a private phone call and I guess the
girlfriend today
when the LA Times a girlfriend was
saying that she did not mean for this to
go
out and she did not release it but there
was a third party involved we don't know
who that is yet who did
right really set so do you guys fear
that the privacy thing we talk about
privacy at some level every week on the
show to do more
in a in a little bit but that the
pricing has completely disappeared
because we've all said things privately
in private conversation
were all the comedy world we can joke
about things that you do it publicly it
could be taken the wrong way much less
with uk2 privately
to do you worry about that we're losing
that at all which in no way
is a defensive anything he said on in
that audiotape obviously
I don't think that we're yeah I i'm a
dreamer two different things I am I'm
afraid of losing
other kinds of things over that system
entirely
ban just I said the wrong thing in a
joke I think we may have given up more
freedom than that
a for this artificial safety
in that system i dont I'm not sure if
there's any real safety at all
and what they provide us with the
security system pic America
right I think they're even referring up
all too are individual safety when
they're recording their wondering what
we're going to wise up and come
I'll about himself think in general
though I don't think we really had the
privacy conversation yeah I think we're
all experimenting with this stuff
and I mean look at social media we we we
give away all of our privacy in order to
connect to people on Facebook and
Twitter and all those places
you know you sign it away when you when
you sing download the app
and so we had to be really even begun to
have a real conversation about
I don't think I'd I don't think the
average person it's hit
their life yet yeah and when that does
then the conversation will really start
well what we're trying to do here which
is why bring it up every do you guys I
to me it seems like the ABA dekhi
absolutely the right thing and Adam
Silver brand new guy you know david
Vitter
somewhere to live it or not they did the
right thing and help up for publicity
goes up obviously this has been going on
before they knew about it before it was
okay before Intel
this former media got hold of it
and comedic aimed at like I said a guns
on a
and they recognize that we have a set
the controls to shoot at
them with words and they're terrified of
these words well
and they even said that they were
they've been wanting to take action
against him for a while but they had
they want to be in lawsuits go down in
the lawsuits kept going down in his
favor
so they really couldn't make the move in
my understanding is that he hadn't done
what he did yesterday
every single team was gonna walk off the
court last night
yeah which relief at all I what back
because I am even if they just delayed
the games a half hour and up
TNT many SBA yeah Arab advertisers
security and the and yes
it was the advertisers that motivated
most to this story in our board members
long
ok table yeah pounding process yet what
did you guys see the
video above the advertisers at staple
center they were literally covering up
advertisers their billboards with the
Virgin America
yes we're going away yeah what kinda
racist has a black girlfriend we've been
talking a lot about this on the Young
Turks
Lancel yeah it was so what's going on
there with that mentality that you could
have a black girlfriend
and then you could say that this girl do
not bring black good
magical talented forget the racist or if
you know any if you care at all about
basketball
you would want to be associated with
he's an amazing guy
yeah it really well what how do you how
do you guys parts that level
Bracewell you know if that that kinda
racism in general is fear
love the other it's less it's a it's
your unconscious psyche
afraid of the thing that unknown the
thing that you can't control the thing
that
that is so different from you that you
can't recognize it
and it leaks out in personalities in all
sorts of interesting ways so
having a black or latina girlfriend you
can
fucker you know so you can have control
over her you can sexually dominate her
that's one way to deal with the other
the unknown
and the other is then to try to control
you know your public space and here's a
man
clearly a ton of money but you look at
the LA Times adds this guy takes out
once a month
you know touting amo I got another ward
with this order
total narcissist he wants to control his
kingdom
and that's one way another way of
dealing with %uh I'm gonna control
MySpace and you would get to come in and
you don't i mean it's
its it's actually not as strange as it
looks yeah is it also sorta that
plantation mentality like
you know we can hack it have the the
black girl in the house
and I don't have to show any lower yet
she's just a utility
to be it up yeah I don't think that's a
great analogy for sure
yeah actually last question is do you
think the NBA should force him to sell
because that's the one thing they
haven't done at this point expand their
some questions
as far as legality because they're their
bylaws are in public
so you know maybe the book the owners
rep to vote on it do you think they
should force it just a really
put the final stamp I guess so I don't
know much about that world but I
what is he going to do I want you the
really have it I
yeah get a oh yeah I was not welcome
yeah
hit you up to the games anyway so i cant
do anything with the point alright well
hopefully he sells
up